they've all sold their kidneys to
survive
the organ trade isn't new in afghanistan
but it's just got more desperate
every single person here is hungry
and poverty is driving already poor
people to even more extreme measures
this man tells us we've no choice we've
already sold our kidneys now we've got
to sell our children
[Music]
and they're suffering terribly the
taliban takeover meant a massive cut in
aid and these are people with few
options
we've taken efforts to conceal their
identities for their own safety it's a
highly conservative society but i'm
allowed into a room with the women
[Music]
they agree to me filming their scars
some just a few months old the women
have sold their kidneys for less than
the men around fifteen hundred dollars
an organ
there's a lucrative trade with many
organs going to iran but the money's
still not enough
most of these women are still teenagers
with multiple babies but few rights
and now they're being forced to sell
their children so they all have a better
chance of survival
no one can tell me to sell my children
but we're struggling to keep them alive
she says and that's why we've thought of
selling them maybe better for them and
we get food for the others
it is a tragic situation and one they
see no quick end to
there is a lot of women there who've
sold their kidneys are now thinking
of the last option which is selling
their children too
the aid is fought over what's here is
far outweighed by the huge need
it's really very hard in afghanistan
right now she says and there are too
many people like me who don't have a
husband or a father to support them
for women who aren't allowed to work
under the taliban and aren't even
allowed to complain about that it's
misery on misery
she's crying telling us her bag of flour
has been stolen
i don't know what i'm going to do she
says
foreign aids not feeding into the
country while politicians wrestle over
dealing with a taliban regime holding
power because they're holding the guns
you can ask everyone here they're happy
this fighter says security is good
a man interrupts yes security's good but
we don't have any money or food
the children's ward of heratz burns unit
is full little people horribly injured
trying to keep warm in midwinter
aisha is in constant pain with both
hands and both feet very badly burned
her family can't afford to pay for the
dressings for her wounds which are now
infected
without surgery in days she'll die but
surgery comes at a cost they can't
afford
and both her grandmother and her doctor
know this probably seals her fate she'll
be taken home to die there
i have a bad sensation because of lack
of materials i have the ability to
to treat him
but
the lack of materials the bad situation
of economic of people don't lead me to
to help him as much as i can
back at the community outside her at
where whole families have already sold
their kidneys we're with the village
elder who's urgently trying to persuade
this family not to sell one of their
babies
i urge the world please don't leave us
alone he says stop this tragedy when
people are selling their children or
part of their bodies
but both parents have already sold their
kidneys they've already lost a child who
starved to death and they still have
eight little mouths to feed
i've already lost one i can't see them
all lose their lives she says at least
someone else will feed them
these are decisions no parent wants to
make
but hunger can break even a mother's
bond with her babies
alex crawford sky news